and good is inaccessible because here in the
health issue there is no plan
that you can access in cost to
Having a prosthesis is very expensive
a boy wants to have a hand and is
500 kilometers in the capital has to
resort to a traditional orthopedics
you have to travel and take action and
hands that can come to the boy who
today it is almost between one thousand and five
One thousand dollars
we are going to do a lot to
a lower cost we are talking about five
Dollars
you can open and close your hand to
grab things or you can also
pull out your fingers and do something much more
copado so to speak that is to put a
Support for cups or a holder for
open bottles or to play with
then here what we are
allowing people is not
only have a hand that allows
do things but have a hand that is
multitask
plus
two
and at the end of the tour we join
take an experience you are not going to
take to the drawer